I'm joined today by Andrew Turner who's
a disabled veteran an activist for
veterans rights he's a former Guantanamo
Bay prison guard an advocate for access
to plant-based health options and for
closing Guantanamo Bay Andrew there's so
much to talk about with you so I'll just
jump right in how long were you a guard
at Gitmo right around nine months okay
and when you went there what was your
sort of general belief about what it was
like there what was going on what your
experience would be like so so I
initially had volunteered to go in 2009
the Navy had a program called the
individual augmentee program where they
would come along and say hey we need
this group of people for these
deployments this option came up to go to
Guantanamo this was after the president
had signed the executive order to close
it so the understanding was we would be
going to be part of the task force that
would be there to close it and I felt
that that was a IIIi wanted to be part
of that versus being there keeping it
open obviously so you were already going
in with the the up of the opinion that
it should be closed down yes sir and why
why did you feel that way you know and
initially they set up Guantanamo maybe
with some form of good intentions I
don't I don't really know I don't I I
don't totally understand or even even
want to try to explain what what those
intentions may have been initially to
keep people safer I guess is is what
always the argument has been about
keeping it open but I've always kind of
viewed it it when we when we passed the
first year or two and and we weren't
focused on due process for detainees you
know and standing up for for for the
rights that that we as as Americans
always seem to hold dear I started to
have kind of an issue with with what was
going on there at the time
was already obviously active duty in the
military so it's much tougher to do
things like protests and other things
when it when it directly reflects some
type of government action and what
impact did being there have on your
mental state on your mental health uh
you know III never knew
had I known now
what impact that would have had um I I
probably would have thought twice about
going down there obviously I tried to go
down there with good intentions I have
quite a bit of empathy for you know
people that are detained indefinitely I
I don't agree with the actions our
government's taken and maybe that
partially affected me but then also
while I was there I early on I was
violently assaulted by it by a
particularly angry detainee that was
trying to injure himself and while we
were trying to keep him from doing that
he started smashing his head into the
floor wound up doing some pretty bad
damage to my right hand to the point
where I no longer have what would be
considered a fully functional hand and
that that definitely affected me but I
think you know also just the the the
amount of time working there definitely
[Music]
changed things for me in about a year
later after I returned I wound up being
diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
disorder and a generalized anxiety
disorder yeah what does the average
person even people who follow what's
what's at least published about what
goes on at Guantanamo Bay what does the
average person not realize about the
day-to-day of what's going on there well
I think I think there's a big assumption
that you know every every guard that
goes down there is somehow complicit and
you know what what many would consider
the evils of our country when when the
reality is many went down there either
voluntarily by you know taking one of
these end of it
jool augmentee sets of orders or going
down there with some type of a unit and
many of them were of the ideal that you
know the three words fair firm and
impartial meant something and it's still
to this day do and and so there's always
this this there's this right or left
thinking about it when when the reality
is it isn't black and white
neither the military presence there nor
you know even the lives of the detainees
it's just not black and white and it's
not easily explained for the average
person to where they would understand
what's going on there
I read the reddit ask me anything that
you did recently sort of a preparation
for our interview and I noticed that
there were a number of questions asked
that that you sort of said you couldn't
really talk about the answers there at
not to clarify is that because the
answers would reveal classified
information or because you you signed a
nondisclosure agreement which is sort of
a very different reason for not being
able to discuss something both both I
mean it's it's you know obviously some
of the work was classified I was
actually attached to task force platinum
which I can't talk about partly due to
its classification but also because of
the non-disclosure agreement that I
signed and so anything that that touches
on operational anything that touches on
specific detainees anything that that
that you know that that we've been
briefed that we can't talk about I can't
talk about and I don't know when that
will ever change yeah do you think that
that is part of the reason why there
isn't more of a proactive uprising about
closing Gitmo because a lot of what goes
on there just never really gets to
people here in the United States no I
think I think the the the far bigger
problem is is we've allowed the
political narrative to become fear over
if it closes and we focused on due
process and we looked at moving
detainees that we plan to try and detain
long term you know through punishments
that our courts decide on I think that
we've
you've allowed the political message to
be permeated by fear of things like
Islamophobia and you know in the the
this concept that somehow they're there
they're going to not escape while
they're at Guantanamo but somehow if we
brought them here to America you know or
to the US and tried them in courts and
then detained them somewhere you know or
at that point if they were found guilty
imprisoned them and somewhere like the
Supermax in Colorado or our you know the
maximum-security prison in Terre Haute
Indiana that somehow they would escape
and be loose or somehow they'd be
allowed to be loose and that's you know
that's the farthest thing from the truth
yeah I mean that argument sort of
implies that we don't we can't really
trust the most secure prisons in the US
right people inside right if the
argument is we even if they're on
American soil in in the most secure of
all prisons those programs just aren't
good enough is what the argument sort of
implies isn't it well that in and that
our US Court system our federal court
system here in America is somehow sub
subpar compared to the military
tribunals that have failed to even try
20 detainees in 15 years I want to talk
a little bit you mentioned PTSD
generalized anxiety as a result of this
incident where you were attacked by a
detainee at Gitmo when I introduced you
I mentioned you're also an advocate for
plant-based health options and one of
those that many people may not have
heard of and I hope I'm pronouncing this
right is Krita kratom how does it
pronounced correctly you'll generally
hear it either kratom or kratom okay
they're not to pronounce what that is
and the controversy surrounding it right
now sure so so kratom kratom is uh is a
it's it's a leaf off a tree generally
grown in Southeast Asia and Indonesia
Borneo imported here into the u.s. up
until this past year for the most part
the FDA and DEA played kind of hands-off
and then the FDA came in and
and did kind of an import alert early in
2015 and they started having the
marshals and customs seized shipments
from you know from vendors and it was
already kind of difficult for the
vendors because then they had to you
know just the way the whole FDA dietary
ingredient rules changed in 1994 with
the de chelly Act it's always been kind
of tough to sell this and market it
because you had to market it is not for
human consumption and and you know it's
just this weird limbo that it was placed
in well then in September first the DEA
came out and and and put in a proposal
of intention to make it a Schedule one
substance right a Schedule at that point
you know a Schedule one substance pretty
much cuts off any kind of research and
there was there was a really promising
researcher already going on so nobody
really understood what why without any
kind of input between the FDA DEA and
the research community and the consumer
community where this came from because
it didn't make a lot of sense they've
since retracted that opened up for
public comments they received record
number of public comments about this we
I just did an interview for my Houghton
podcast a couple days ago and the
there's a social working there's a
social worker and her team that are
actually working on breaking down all
the public comments and they've even
found that it's over ninety nine percent
support keeping it legal and for people
who don't know Andrew I mean we're
talking about something that if I
understand correctly in small doses the
effects are caffeine like and in larger
doses is it is it fair to say similar to
opiates III wouldn't say opiates per se
but but it does there is some there's 27
alkaloids 27 27 plus alkaloids in the
plant itself as the way you know
consumers would get it and a couple of
those alkaloids would be opioid like not
opiate opioid there's a little bit of a
difference and that's due to how it
interacts with the opioid
ders in the body but even the
researchers have said that it would you
couldn't really call it an opioid and
definitely not an opiate because that
would mean it would be coming from the
opium plan and it doesn't it's the trees
a little more related to the coffee
plant than it is anything else but it
does it it does have some analgesic
effects you know it does interact with
the opioid receptor so a lot of people
use it for pain management there's some
that take it and it's become really
effective for a lot of people getting
off very hard opiate substances and even
things like suboxone and methadone that
for a long time was the only way to get
off like a heroin addiction but then
they in they in turn created you into a
methadone or a a suboxone addict and
they even had far worse withdrawal
symptoms so this gave a lot of people a
chance at kind of a new life and so when
this you know when this this proposal to
schedule it came out it I mean it
crushed a lot of people it was it was
very scary to think that the government
would take away something that was
helping so many well it seems to me like
a total pharmaceutical industrial
complex attack right I mean when you
talk about something that all of a
sudden is going to schedule one
something that wasn't even on the radar
of so many people for so long at a time
when we're learning more and more about
its uses it seems like a money grab from
me and and the key thing is as you
mentioned it seems to be effective in
weaning people off of opiates and for
for many companies that means losing
money doesn't it and I think that's part
of it I think that's you know there's
also been a couple of trade groups from
the from the supplement industry that uh
that for a while now have tried to get
kratom x' legal clarification removed
and it completely taken off the market
maybe partly because they have to go
through such stringent laws that they
wanted everybody to but instead of
saying hey why isn't there better
regulation of this they wanted it banned
too and it comes and you come to find
out that some of these companies also
represent Bayer
BASF DuPont and these large chemical
companies
not just pharmaceutical but also
chemical companies that make quote
unquote supplements sure well listen
we're going to be following both what
goes on with kratom and what goes on at
Guantanamo Bay I really want to thank
you for sharing your story today we have
been speaking with Andrew Turner who's a
disabled veteran activist for veterans
rights and also a former Guantanamo Bay
prison guard I really appreciate you
talking to us today
David David can I share one last thing
please there's a there's a petition to
the White House going on right now if
somebody if anyone is interested in
signing it to keep kratom legal we're
still working on those petitions to the
White House this one you can find at the
American kratom associations website
just google American kratom Association
there's more information about the the
petition to the White House currently
we're just trying to keep it legal and
accessible for anyone that wants to have
that access